this massive air force c-17 plane landed
in the u.s sunday carrying precious
cargo 78 000 pounds of hypoallergenic
formula from switzerland these are the
first two flights of operation fly
formula as the biden administration
works to ease a nationwide shortage
president biden invoking the defense
production act the wartime law allows
the government to force suppliers to
give formula manufacturers the key
ingredients they desperately need
if the federal government just backed
off and let the market function like
it's supposed to we wouldn't need
military intervention or emergency
policies designed for war to stock
grocery store shelves with baby formula
this crisis is largely the result of
protectionism regulation and central
planning of the sort that both democrats
and republicans want more of in
washington why was the bible
administration so slow to respond to
this crisis reporters want to know why
the government didn't respond more
quickly to this shortage but the actual
solution is for the government to be
less involved entirely i do wonder dr
caleb if this is a shortage that you
believe could have been prevented do you
think the fda was too slow here are you
disturbed a better question is why
didn't the biden administration clear
the way for the private sector to react
to price signals like it does in every
other industry food suppliers would have
started stockpiling european-made
formulas months ago if only u.s tariffs
and regulations weren't an obstacle so
how does this work in practice first the
federal government prohibits importing
many european-made baby formulas simply
because they fail to meet fda labeling
requirements but europe is the world's
leading exporter of baby formula thanks
to major producers based in germany the
netherlands and britain if fda labeling
regulations are so necessary why is it
that infants all over the globe safely
consume formula made in europe meanwhile
about 98 of the formula sold in the
united states is produced domestically
we've sealed ourselves off from a robust
and safe global market in addition to
the labeling requirements the government
imposes huge tariffs on foreign formula
to protect domestic manufacturers and
the american dairy industry now the us
is heroically flying in european-made
baby formula but just a year ago border
patrol officers were bragging about
heroically seizing it these two policies
of regulation and protectionism work in
tandem to scare away foreign suppliers
for example let's say you're running a
baby formula manufacturing firm in
germany you would have zero incentive to
spend the money to earn fda approval for
your labels because high tariffs would
make your product too expensive to
compete in the u.s market our retailers
need to have the flexibility to actually
sell and our consumers to buy
whatever type of product that they have
and to do so safely so we've got to
waive a bunch of regulations that
traditionally make sense but don't make
sense in this crisis did european-made
baby formula suddenly become less
hazardous does passing formula through
the hands of the us military magically
make it safe for american babies to
drink or maybe the regulations and
tariffs are designed to protect big
businesses not babies and never should
have existed in the first place utah
senator mike lee introduced a bill that
would temporarily wave the tariffs on
baby formula and remove the fda labeling
regulations but
how about scrapping them all together
there's also an important lesson here
for economic nationalists who claim that
international trade is a vulnerability
excluding even more foreign-made
products is critical for our national
security missouri senator josh hawley
argued last year he has suggested
tightening the made in america rules
that already govern federal procurement
to include the entire commercial market
if howley got his way all industries
could become just as vulnerable to
supply shocks as baby formula will we
one day have to replace our 2.5 trillion
dollar international shipping and
logistics industry with emergency
military aircraft crisscrossing the
skies the biden administration and
congress get to come off like heroes
rushing to feed american babies left to
go hungry because of the supposed
cruelty of the free market but that's
all an act don't be fooled about the
real cause of this shortage